this is fun for me oh lisa rinna is
having fun all right
sharing her thoughts on her daughter
amelia gray hamlin's relationship with
scott disick
does mom approve yes i do i actually do
very much so yes very much so the 19
year old model has been romantically
linked to the 37 year old reality star
since they were first spotted together
late last year
on tuesday lisa who shares amelia with
her hubby harry hamlin
took to her insta stories to poke a
little fun at her daughter's new bow
this is fun the real housewives of
beverly hills star shared
this paparazzi shot of amelia and scott
walking on the beach together scott in a
bucket hat
lisa wrote alongside it quote welp we
both
seem to share a love of bucket hats then
she made
this side-by-side collage complete with
a laughing crying emoji
noting that they're both rocking bucket
hats
this begs the question who wore it best
gosh you know it's everything as for
amelia and scott
things are seemingly heating up between
the pair a source recently told e.t that
the father of three
is planning a temporary move to miami
for a change of scenery and
pace and amelia well she's down to go
with him
amelia is planning on moving in with him
scott was lonely when he and sofia
richie broke up
which is one of the reasons he and
amelia got together so quickly
they've been getting a bit more serious
for now scott has been having a good
time with amelia
and when it comes to lasting love amelia
has her famous parents to look up to
here's what she told et in 2017 during a
chat with her mom
and older sister delilah what have you
guys learned from their love story
i mean it's so rare these days to have a
couple that's together i feel like and i
have parents that are together
so it's just really cool that our
parents are together especially in
hollywood like that's really rare
um so i definitely look up to their
relationships are you getting a little
emotional here yes
i mean you know you do your best and
we're lucky we are
we've stayed together for 25 years
that's 150 in hollywood years
it's like dog years but hollywood year
so what's the secret i don't know
i really don't what's the secret i
respect each other and you don't set
each other to really high standards i
think that's
yeah spoken right out of the mouths of
babe
right here